He said, "One of my greatest joys as a
Christian is advocating for Israel and
forming alliances to defend
Judeo-Christian civilization."
>> Done. Is that the letter? Is that the
letter he sent to you? So, he sent you a
letter. I could come and say, "Look, I
can have disagreement with individuals."
For example, if I disagreement with a
person in the da, I can say, "Brother,
you know, I love you. You're my brother.
We're in the same course together, da da
da, but I have to disagree with you, and
I have to tell you that, bro, you are
wrong in this matter." And blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah. If
somebody reads that top contest, how
does it look like? There you go, guys.
He was changing his opinion. Yes, they
don't want to read that part of the
letter.
Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, Masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this message
inshallah a new project that's only
$500,000 and believe me if every single
one of us give £1, £10, £100, £1,000
that's going to be something you will
never regret on your makayama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go. but your deeds and your
makyama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Subhan Allah. As we're looking into this
whole situation with the child's
assassination and killing and I've made
this clear many videos and I want to
make this clear and clear again and I
want to stick by the words of Omaran. We
do not condone the killing of anybody
for that matter. Neither will we be
mourning his death. Let's make that very
crystal clear. We are not shy about that
at all. somebody who was pro- genocide
which he later on opened his eyes which
is the reason why many people millions
of people are blaming Israel because
they know the capabilities Israel has
they've attacked USS Liberty ships uh as
a force attack they have when 9/11
happened they had connections the five
Zionist connected to Mosad clearly
laughing Zionist um be at the JFK
Kennedy's killing um and we know the
capabilities of Israel and they are
behind all these evils around the world
and people are waking up and this
Charlie Kirk when he started to talk out
against them and when he we're going to
listen for oursel firsthand inshallah
even Candice Owens is calling him out
why is Fox News a major TV channel
giving air to Benjamin to read this
letter that supposedly Charlie Kirk sent
to him and Charlie Ker was having issues
with his funders he was fearing for his
life here is this u individual here as
we can see his name is I don't known
Jason Hickle. I don't agree with
everything he says. Let me make that
clear. I believe some stuff he says is
quite anti-semitic. I don't agree with
that. Uh but let's watch it for ourel
in. This is getting really, really
weird. And in my next video I'm going to
be doing about this guy who's apparently
the culprit who killed Charlie Kirk.
Things don't add up, guys. Things don't
add up. Let's carry on. And Owens just
exposed that Israel's Netanyahu lied
about the letter that Charlie Kirk wrote
to him last night. One day after the
tragedy, Netanyahu booked himself a
prime times law on US national
television to read a letter from Charlie
Kirk about how much Charlie loved
Israel. Why would he find a need to do
that, guys? Why would he book the TV
station to what did he cuz he knows the
last words the the last movements of
Charlie Kirk was what? Scrutinizing and
slowly changing his opinions on Israel.
He's trying to make the people remember
him as what? He left supporting Israel,
which is a lie. Which is a lie. and
we're going to go to Candace Owens tweet
and then we're going to watch the video
on the Fox News channel.
>> Except that's not what the letter said
according to Candace Owens who is a very
close friend of Charlie Kirk. So now
she's coming out and saying Nanyahu
needs to release that full letter. Let
Charlie speak for himself. Don't put
fake words in his mouth. And oh by the
way, why are you lying about this?
You're the leader of a nation who's at
war with seven countries halfway across
the world and you're booking a prime
time slot on US TV airwaves to come and
lie about Charlie one day after this
tragedy. What is going on here? Not to
mention, Candace also added that yes,
Charlie was at war with his donors over
the question of Israel and the war.
>> And who was his donors? This is for
context. Who who is his donors? Yes. Uh
Christian Zionist or Zionist themselves.
They were his majority of donors.
Majority they were throwing money at
him. So Christian Zionist Zionist of the
same thing and he was having issues with
them. Why? Listen carefully. Israel and
the war in Iran. So this was really
heating up. Things were really bad.
Charlie was fearing for his life. And
now you got this. What? What is going
on? Do not listen to people who say stop
asking questions because they do not
have your best interest at heart. They
definitely don't have Charlie's best
interest at heart and they don't want
you to find out the truth.
>> There you go. Because he was opposing
the war with Iran. We went and met
Donald Trump. This is the reason why
they took him out. Because someone so
close as an ally like that, if he turns
his back, they have to get rid of him.
Get rid of him. Let's go. Now, this is
the Fox News interview of the Satan.
Watch this. They're giving him air time.
Watch this, guys. It's crazy. You can't
make this stuff up.
>> Uh Charlie Kirk, of course, for all of
us who know him, who knew him,
remembered for so many things today. And
one of them is his staunch support of
Israel. He visited in 2018. I remember
that was the first time I met him. It
was at the US embassy after it had moved
to Jerusalem from Tel Aviv. That was one
of then President Trump's first term
decisions.
>> Why are they look look they not only
Benjamin Netanyahu but they start off
with what was he known for? Support of
Israel. Why are they so obsessed with
leaving this in our memories that
Charlie Kirk supported Israel which we
know he did but the tide was changing.
He was changing opinions. He was having
issue with his donors. He met Donald
Trump to say why don't go to don't go to
war with Iran. He was he mentioned so
many stuff in my other video that I
mentioned. This look at how it starts
off guys. It's it's orchestrated. Watch.
>> And I Charlie was there also the
following year supporting Israel's war
against Hamas and against the
anti-semitism that followed. Watch.
>> When we as Christians go to Israel, we
are celebrated and treated like the most
amazing you could ever imagine. Okay.
Israel changed my life.
>> Look at this. They've even got clips now
of Charlie Kirk. They're like, "Okay,
now the the the anchor saying it. Oh, he
supported." No, no, no. We're going to
cut snips snippets of we know he said
that. It's about he was changing his
views. Look, now they showing you how he
supported them. Watch this. And then the
Satan Yahoo comes. Watch. And then we're
going to go to Candace Owens's tweets.
>> When I went to Israel, I was reading
Bible stories my whole life as a
committed Christian. And all of a
sudden, I had a life-changing
experience. the nation of Israel
actually has a place in God's plan for
us on this planet. There's something
special about Israel and I think we have
a moral commitment to that land. The
Israeli community has been very
welcoming of us as Christians and our
faith to the homeland and it will not go
unnoticed. The Israeli foreign ministry
said this morning, Charlie Kirk was a
steadfast friend of Israel and a true
ally of the Jewish people. He stood
proudly for the Judeo-Christian values
which bind Israel and America. and
Charlie's fearless commitment to truth
and freedom cost him his life. Violence
may have taken him, but it cannot
silence his legacy. May his memory be a
blessing. The prime minister of Israel,
Benjamin Netanyahu, in focus now.
>> Oh, here we go. We got the Satan here
that he's booked that. Can you imagine?
There's a war going on. He's stopped
everything. Why? Because this matters.
This is important. Okay, this is
important because he knows the people
that f child are waking up and saying
hold on a second was actually turned
against them etc. And that's why they
took him out. So they have to put this
no support us don't support look what
said
>> prime minister you have your own
memories of Charlie Kirk please share
them. Well, Harris, before I do that, I
have to say that we're just heartbroken.
Myself, my my wife, my family, my son,
actually, and his 2019 visit to Israel.
Had lunch with him
>> and his wife Erica. Uh we're shattered
first as human beings because a great
human being has been taken from us. Uh
he's was an extraordinary friend. And uh
he um you know he he said he wrote me a
letter on on May 2nd.
>> Okay, good. He wrote he wrote a letter.
Okay, show us the letter, man. Show us
the letter. Read it in full. Read in
full. If you book the whole slot, read
it in full. Okay, read it in full. And
who do we how do we know where is
evidence for that? And Candace Owens is
calling this out, which we're going to
come to tweets in a minute. Look what he
says
>> here. He said, "One of my greatest joys
as a Christian is advocating for Israel
and forming alliances to defend
Judeo-Christian civilization."
>> Done. Is that the letter? Is that the
letter he sent to you? So he sent you a
letter. I could come and say, "Look, I
can have disagreement with individuals."
For example, if I disagreement with a
person in the da, I can say, "Brother,
you know, I love you. You're my brother.
We're in the same course together." D,
but I have to disagree with you and I
have to tell you that, bro, you are
wrong in this matter. And I have to tell
you that what you're doing is wrong and
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah. If
somebody reads that top contest, how
does it look like? There you go, guys.
He was changing his opinion. Yes, they
don't want to read that part of the
letter. Where is it? Where is it? I show
him. because own is calling this maz
out.
>> A few weeks before the tragedy
yesterday, I I called him and I spoke to
him and I said, "Please come to Israel."
I invited him to Israel and sadly that
visit will not take place. But he was he
was a defender of our common
Judeo-Christian civilization. He was
unbelievably excited to walk at the
footsteps of Jesus here. He uh he valued
our bond, the bond between America and
Israel. He uh
>> my friend, you despise Jesus. You swear.
You say he's burning a feces. What are
you talking about?
>> You know, he uh uh did so many things to
defend free speech. He had his truth. He
stood up for it. But he said, "You can
you can come and debate me." He invited
that debate. He certainly didn't invite
the violence, the horrible violence that
tried to silence him. And you know, this
is a worldwide problem. the the people
on on the, you know, on the extremes,
the the Islamists, the radical Islamists
and the their union with the
ultrargives. Interesting. Ultra
progressives. My friend, the guy that
shot him was so far right. The reason he
killed Charlie Kirk is because he didn't
believe him to be far right enough
because he works with you guys. Okay?
So, I don't know what you're talking
about there.
>> They often speak about human rights.
They speak about
>> the freaking hell is what to do with
this, bro. Look how he brings he's
trying to distort it. Now guys, what
we're going to do is inshallah we're
going to go to Candace Owens's tweets.
Let's go to Candace Owens's tweets. Look
for yourself guys. She is calling it out
as it is. Watch this now. Okay. Candace
Owen said the following. And not just
before we go her tweets. Somebody a a
Zionist says, "Your day will come." Yes.
All lies will be revealed. And he she he
replies, "Your day will come." That is a
direct threat in her life. And she calls
him a filthy rodent. Okay. Now, no show
today because I'm not feeling u deeply I
am feeling deeply angered is personal. I
intend to destroy every lie. So, be sure
to pedal them very carefully. BB brought
up a letter himself severely
misrepresented the context of it. I'm
calling on him to publish the entire
thing. For some reason, that seems to
have sent you on an emotional spiral
because you lied like him. I see you for
exactly what you asked to this dirt bag
Laura Luma. Okay. It says the man
literally booked himself an American
prime time show and held up a letter to
represent it as a love letter to Israel.
He did that intentionally. It was it was
naked deception and propaganda. Let the
world hear Charlie in his own words.
Rightly so. Be very wary and suspicious
of the people who are already telling
you telling us to stop asking questions
about the Charlie Kirk assassination.
The father of the shooter was a
27year-old veteran of the Washington
County Sheriff's Department. We need to
continue to ask questions absolutely
about everything. I want to know
everything that there is about to know
about everyone around this kid. Yes. And
she goes, "All lies will be revealed. It
is 100% true that Charlie opposed war
with Iran and was fighting with his
donors over Israel." As Tiger Carson
just shared on Megan Kelly's show, this
is why I'm discomforted by the
intentional lie uh by omission that BB
told the Fox News about the letter
Charlie wrote to him. BB Netanyahu lied
about the context content of the letter
Charlie wrote to him in May. It was a
lie by severe admission and it ain't
sitting right with me. He held the
letter in his hand and propagandized it.
He should publish the entire thing.
Brothers and sisters, the plot is
getting thicker.
The world is waking up. It is the
beginning of the end of Israel. Like
Allah says in the Quran, they plan and
Allah plans and Allah is the best of
planners. They are finished. They are
finished. Alhamdulillah, brothers and
sisters, you can see the whole world is
waking up. These people are the evil of
every atrocity that happens around the
world. They are behind it. Zionists are
behind it. They are behind it. And let
me tell you something, their Samson
option. They have nuclear weapons. And
if their existence, their terrorist
state existence is jeopardized, they
will nuke everybody. Mark words. Till
next time.